People often ask me in an accusatory way: "Are you an atheist?"
I want them to be a world and I am not associated with any groups
I do not follow any movements and follow what is dictated to my mind, when someone follows a doctrine
Or movement, it becomes a pot of this doctrine
When you want to discuss something, they'll tell you
They already know everything important that you should know because of this connection to the doctrine.
But sorry for this is not a way to discuss, it is better to explore
Each other actually rather than sticking labels together and emphasizing that we know
What will happen in advance.
What people try to know is my position on religion, spirituality or God
The closest word I describe myself to is (a skeptical atheist)
This term refers to the 19th century and was written by Huxley to refer to someone who does not know but is
Has yet to see evidence of his belief but is willing to accept the evidence if any
But if there is no evidence, he does not have to think about something without evidence.
There are many atheists. "All skeptics are atheists." "Well always
Atheists say I am an atheist. "And I find this a deceptive thing.
Others did so. I feel flattered when people are interested in knowing about my life
To collect information on this page. The page says "Neil Degrass is an atheist" but I say
This is not really "real", "Neil Degrass is an atheist skeptical" and a week later I visited the page again if it was not done
Even though I did it twice in the same week - I said, "What's this?"
"It seems I have to put it another way," so I said well, "Neil Digras, who says atheists widely
He is an atheist, he really is (a skeptical atheist). "
Some will say, well, that is - "You are unfair to the fact that they are in fact
"No, they are not the same and I will tell you why, the atheists I know
They are proud to be so active atheists. They are atheists
They seek to change policies and engage in debates. But I do not have time
No effort and I have no desire. I am a scholar and a teacher. My goal is to push people
To think directly first of all out of curiosity towards the natural world
That's what I am. I do not care about the rest
It is strange that the word atheist is present. I do not play golf. Is there a word "non-golf player"?
Do not the golfers crowd and plan. Do non-skiers are called a description and congregate
For a real forum they do not skate? I can not do that
I can not gather with others and discuss how many people among us do not believe in God. Quite simply
I do not have the effort to do so, so being skeptical distinguishes me from the behavior of atheists
Whether there is a large space shared between the two categories or not, and at the end
Today I do not prefer my rankings at all